but I'd like to now introduce the next
speaker
that's Brian Kolb from the University of
Lethbridge Brian's research focuses on
how neurons in the cerebral cortex
change in response to experiences drugs
hormones and injury and how these
changes influence behavior over 40 years
he has identified the rules that govern
the effects of cerebral injury on
different developmental ages his work
has fueled new treatments to help
victims of cerebral injury Kolb was
first to demonstrate how new brain cells
grow to restore cerebral function both
in development and adulthood and the
first to show with Terri Robinson that
psychoactive drugs produce permanent
changes in neuronal structures in
cerebral structures and that these
change changes influenced later brain
plasticity so thank you Brian
thank everybody for coming
as a native Calgarian I can tell you
that when I moved to last bridge from
Montreal in 1976 I had never been there
so I bet none of you have either
normally when I go across the country I
have to point out that last bridge is
not the city between Calgary and
Edmonton but you know that I hope has a
record I guess of being a little windier
than Calgary but it ain't true okay if
we can see you the next slide please
can I see I can change them okay my
take-home message is there you can read
it just as well as I can one of the
points I want to make that Tom did not
make was that it's not just the events
that occur after birth that are
important it's events that occur before
birth and before conception and I'll
show you that that are important and
determining who you are who you're
bringing it is and I think that since my
mother is dead I can blame her for
everything that's happened and things
that happened to her before she met my
dad okay a lot of people are puzzled and
they say why can you use rats to learn
anything about children and so I thought
I'd just say a little bit about how we
can do this so rats are very
clever albertans don't know about rats
because they're not legal here but they
are wonderful animals they can be
trained to do all sorts of things and so
we can do a lot of behavioral tests and
you can see around here learning to
reach through that slot to get food just
an easy example to give we can also
infer the mechanisms for the effects
that Tom talked about and I'm going to
talk about from what's known as
epigenetics that was one of the slides
he didn't show you but the idea is that
you are not just your DNA it's not all
on so you have toenails and hair and
skin and brain and they all have the
same DNA but the cells don't look the
same
that's because different genes are
turned on or off and the idea is that
experiences can affect that finally we
can see that gorgeous thing on the right
that's a neuron and this trial mentioned
you've got 86 million of those give or
take a few and we can actually look at
the structure of the neuron and he gave
you a sort of a qualitative view of
stressed neuron we can actually see how
it changes we can use that to infer
changes in the organization of the brain
now you can see here that the brain
starts developing rather early at 25
days there's something of gestation is
something that's going to be a brain
it's not really a brain but there's this
long period of time here that the brain
is being affected by what's going on in
the mom and around the mom but when the
child is born that brain doesn't look
like your brain so there's a lot of
things that are going to go on
especially in that first thousand days
as Tom mentioned now Tom mentioned the
prefrontal cortex I'm a prefrontal
chauvinist by which I mean I think it's
the most important part of the brain and
you can stand for many things it is you
can see here that this is an increase in
the number of synapses in the prefrontal
cortex it reaches a peak around age five
and then it starts to drop and it drops
very quickly during adolescence peri
adolescence and so those of you who've
had teenage girls know what I'm talking
about that they're losing about a
hundred thousand synapses a second so
hundred thousand gone hundred thousand
gone and so after the day that you put
up with them
you remember after saying to my wife why
did we do this and the next day I say oh
it's a different person
all night she was changing her brain but
of course we went through this again so
there's this period here that's really
important and a second this is the first
thousand days and a little more in the
second period in during adolescence but
notice it continues to prune until at
least the third the end of the third
decade so it's a very protracted period
now what I've been studying for the last
40 or 50 years is the various of arias
events that can affect brain development
obviously in ten minutes I can't tell
you very much about them but I'm gonna
tell you something about good bad and
ugly experiences good perhaps the the
goodest if you like or the best now that
we've seen is tactile stimulation so if
you look here you can see maternal
massage you can see what's called
kangaroo care for obvious reasons so you
can see the skin-to-skin contact this is
a rat mother rat being breast of the
child's hairbrush I know it looks a
little gruesome that was the artist who
drew it sort of spiky but you can brush
the rat there's a child getting her baby
getting massaged and there's a little
baby rat with a little paintbrush now
why is this important well it turns out
that you can get to the brain through
the skin so if we look here at the
effective tactile stimulation so what we
did in this experiment was to do this to
actively stimulate baby rats you line
them up like little Vienna sausages and
then you just go up and down with your
little paintbrush we use a Swifter now
because you can do all at once it's
pretty fast you can do that 15 minutes
twice a day for two weeks leave them
alone for the next four months and then
look at all sorts of cognitive a motor
skills and this just does the motor
skill because it's easy this is the
accuracy of reaching through to grab
food they're very good with their digits
and you can see the animals that had
tactile stimulation are way better than
the animals who did not have it so
that's the only intervention we did so
how can this happen how can you have
that well it's because the brain has
been altered by this tactile stimulation
the circuits have changed we can see
effects on cognitive behaviors as well
as
motor behaviors and social behaviors how
does this happen well it's true of
humans as well as a study showing that
women who have postpartum depression the
more that they calculus Tim you late the
babies the better off the babies are now
how does this happen it turns out that
when you fall and you scrape your hand
what do you do you rub it when you rub
it what happens it feels better why does
it feel better because the skin is
making stuff that actually repairs it
that stuff it's making if you remember
back to biology 30 or 20 all those years
ago the brain and scanner from the same
germ cell there they respond to the same
thing so the stuff you're making in your
skin goes through the blood-brain
barrier it affects the brain it turns
out to be a good thing that one of the
things that the skin produces is called
fgf2 which the brain has receptors for
so you can actually get to the brain
through the skin so the tactile
stimulation is marvelous way of getting
through now one of the things that's
unfortunate about the schools now is you
can't touch the kids when they're
stressed but I'm going to suggest you
they're one of the most important things
you would have to do is detect you guys
are nodding touch the touch the kids
okay how about bad Tom alluded to bad
examples here are pre-conceptual stress
gestational stress we'll give you a
quick example of both how would you
stress a Rath well there's a variety of
ways you can put them in some sort of
confined space they don't like that very
much neither do i or you can expose them
to the order of predators you can put
them on a little platform you can take
the babies away and so on all sorts of
ways you can stress them and you can
measure how that happens and if you do
that if we take dads and we stress them
before they're mated with moms so we
stress them for 40 days and then when
they're made it with the moms and we
look at their babies four months after
they're born which in rats world is
they're adults what you can see is that
there are fewer connections in the
offspring brain they're actually fewer
neurons we have decreased gene
expression in the offsprings brain so we
have that epigenetic effect and we have
reduced motor and cognitive abilities
how bad is this it's equivalent to
having how two perinatal brain injury so
if we look here
and using again the same behavior just
to make it easy this is the accuracy
this is the control animal as accuracy
and this is the animal the only
experience it had that's different is
its dad was stressed before it was
conceived we see similar effects on
cognitive behaviors and social behaviors
so that pre-conceptual stress is
sufficient to change the way the brain
develops okay didn't work
gestational stress does more or less the
same thing Tom showed you the example of
those neurons so we have smaller brain
and adulthood so what happens is the mum
is stressed during the mid that
basically the second trimester and
partway through the third and then it's
stopped
we see change in gene expression we see
abnormal play behavior we see anxious
animals cognitive impairments and again
you can see this simple bit of the
dendrite in the stress brain versus the
normal brain now if we look at natural
disasters in Canada up until recently
you know what the biggest national
natural disaster ever was that we just
had it but up to that time was the
Quebec ice storm in 1998 a lot of people
were without power for up to six weeks
or two or two months you could you've
seen the pictures you remember what
happened but it's an interesting way to
study the effects of stress because a
lot of women hadn't been to become
pregnant yet that's pre-conceptual
stress or they were pregnant or they'd
had their children so you've got
pre-conceptual gestational perinatal
stress or none at all
and what you can do then is you can
study the kids and so I just said that
children are being followed with
behavior with brain scans and with
epigenetics and if you look at the data
it turns out these kids were measured at
two five point five eight point five and
eleven point five years of age they're
now thirteen more or less years of age
in terms of the analysis we have a drop
in IQ of about ten points that's not
insignificant
in the kids who had the gestational
stress they have [ __ ] language
development
they have [ __ ] motor skills they
have abnormalities and social
interactions and play behavior and in
addition we see epigenetic effects now
this is going to seem like a weird graph
it's not it's really easy to understand
what you have up here is a scale of
really stressed to not stressed and what
the authors did was to say okay there's
a line about here this these are
stressed and these aren't and the color
of the bars here reflects where their
genes are turned on or off the only
point you want to get from this is that
the ones that are on this side the color
is different these are all different
genes the color is different than on
this side these are from their kids when
they're 13 years old so 13 years after
their mom was stressed and they were in
utero we can see a difference in their
blood in the expression of genes in
hundreds of hundreds of genes tomboys
was going to expand on ugly but didn't
so I'll just I was going to be speaking
before him the big point here about
poverty is that poverty is the worst
experience kids can have and one of the
things he had a slide that we didn't see
but basically if you look at the
development of the language regions in
the brain they're [ __ ] in children
who come from families who me income is
less than $50,000 total income that's
actually not as low as you might think
in terms of poverty but that those are
the results from the u.s. that's
correlated with poor language skill
development and other cognitive problems
as well okay to finish off can we
reverse bad things the answer is yes we
can reverse bad things there's a variety
of ways to do this I'm going to pick on
tactile stimulation but point out
there's other ways one has died and Tom
alluded to diet another one is to mess
with neuro trophic factors such as fgf2
which is the one I said it's in the skin
so if we simply use tactile stimulation
or environmental stimulation can we
reverse the effects for example of
gestational stress and the answers yeah
so if we look at tactile stimulation
i've already told you what that is
so you've got gestational stress then
we're going to actively stimulate the
babies afterwards just try and reverse
those effects or we can put animals in
complex environments now I want you to
see those environments as being the
opposite of poverty there's lots of
things in there they have toys as a
value judgment here but there are toys
they can play with there are lots of
conspecifics they can play with there's
lots of activity there's lots of extra
food stuffs and so on and that reverses
the effects of those early experiences
so we can do it so to conclude it's more
or less what tom completed with we're
kind of boring since we do the same
things but brain development is
influenced by a lot of positive and
negative experiences it's not all
negative a lot of positive things and I
told you about one example of positive
was tactile stimulation
another one is parent-infant interaction
another one is peer interactions the
negative one's more obvious stress drugs
and so on these experiences alter brain
and behavioral development through
changes in gene expression among other
things but that's the major mechanism
that we are lude to and it's possible to
intervene but you have to do it early
you want to do it as soon as you can
and you certainly want to do it before
adolescence because during that
adolescent period when the brain is
really changing again it's really
vulnerable what's the one thing you
don't want those kids doing during that
adolescent period when the brain is
changing marijuana alcohol nicotine
because it's having an effect on the
brain that's not like the effect on our
brains it's a different effect it has a
high incidence of psychotic sequelae
later on so there's those two periods in
particular that you want to intervene
and you saw the Tom Tom slide from from
Hecate's showing the decrease in
effectiveness cost effectiveness the
later you go and I have in my last
minute I'm done thank you
[Applause]
so again the same routine we have mics
for people who would like to ask
questions and we'll take those to you
and Amy we can also take one that's
online we'll go to Suzanne first
hello Brian that was fantastic as usual
thank you very much I'm just wondering
is is touch and holding the same as
tactile stimulation yes or as good as
yeah contact let's call it that
holding not shaking right yes yeah in
fact they don't even have to touch the
child you can use a broad spectrum light
on bare skin and then well I don't know
if it's true humans it's true of rats
and that's effective so you just got to
do enough to turn on that those systems
but yes you don't have to necessarily
stroke it although in our hands we
believe stroking is more effective
because you're affecting more skin than
if you're just holding but in the
kangaroo care and in South America where
they hold the kids the kids are just in
a constant harness yeah and so I guess
that would be if you're saying stroking
works then stroking would be the same as
having a hand like is it something about
a physical touch in babies or humans or
is a paintbrush good enough we just
paint all the kids in kindergarten we
could paint all the kids long as it's on
skin ah thank you are there questions in
the room
hi I'm not sure if this is particularly
well it's somewhat relevant but I'm
interested in when you were introduced
about the psychoactive drugs having a
permanent effect on the brain and if you
might be able to speak to that for a few
moments
sure so psychoactive drugs are drugs
that affect behavior and they do that by
changing the brain every psychoactive
drug you're exposed to leaves a
footprint in the brain one exposure to
nicotine the footprint goes away but in
our studies giving Rass equivalent of
the amount of nicotine that you would
get from one cigarette a day for 14 days
four months later we can see the change
in the brain so every psychoactive drug
is having that footprint if you are
exposed to these drugs in utero the
footprint is different than it is if it
you're exposed to those drugs when
you're 30 years old but nonetheless
there is a footprint there is also a
footprint if the drug is given pre
conceptually to Dad's we haven't done
mom's to this point I have no doubt that
it's going to be true so what what's the
footprint the structure of neural
circuits is altered and is this good or
bad well it's a thing it isn't
necessarily good or bad it's just a
thing that happens I don't know if that
answers your question sufficiently
oh okay so if you're giving drugs for
things like ADHD so you're giving
methylphenidate for ADHD does that
affect the brain yeah it does but that's
the whole point is that you want to
change the brain so in that case it's a
good thing methylphenidate it's a little
unusual than that the effects aren't as
persistent as say nicotine and that's
why you have to keep taking it you'd
think well you wouldn't have to keep
taking but there's two effects one is
the change in the brain and the others
the enhance brain activity particularly
in prefrontal cortex leading to enhanced
attention so we do have time Amy if you
have it online nothing from the chat
room yeah if you could take a mic to Amy
sorry yeah we'll just take one online to
make sure we engage those folks melanie
lukovitch is asking where would children
with autism fit in this situation do
they have too many synaptic connections
which make them hyper Sennett of to
touch that's one of the hypotheses
yeah but they that they do have enhanced
neural activity leading to this extreme
reaction to touch and we do have one
former student who's in Cardston who
works for a little mental health who's
actually taking babies at risk for
autism ie they have a sibling or a
cousin with autism and tactically
stimulating them from birth to see if it
can reduce the incidence or not we don't
know yet what that outcome is going to
be we can take one more question in the
room I think there was thank you very
much for your presentation I was just
interested to find out did you notice
who identify difference between paternal
versus maternal stress in pre-conceptual
stress I suppose the effects on the
moment of that are surprisingly similar
in terms of stress as well as other
positive things so we were surprised
that it was so similar but it is okay
thank you everyone and please hold any
questions that those of you in the room
who had hands almost raised and online
I'm sure we'll have more coming in so
we'll have time at the end of all four
to ask more questions